welcome to this video I'm playing
flashlight FM flashlight okay let's see
an open Cecilia okay so what do we have
on this line the oldest nights is six
which are always liked for white but
it's not like I'm an expert check yeah
the CC 352 I don't know there are some
some gambit lines even but this is well
this should be a possible line let's
let's put it that way ok Knight f6 sound
check it at least the bishops but I'm
not in good shape in terms of
development here
yeah do I need to take it I mean if I
take on a 60 do I ever castle are not
not really a parent I do not necessarily
need to cancel but yeah i don't i don't
really know it looks looks pretty okay
for black disposition can i play let's
say b3 and c4 or something like that and
then maybe we should be too yeah this
looks like a decent to set up it only
looks terribly slow I mean like it might
not work for some concrete reason but
okay he cannot castle as well of course
so he has to spend some time King f7 and
then moves like that so probably
probably it is okay if I get in c4
Bishop b2 and short castle white is
excellent but do I really get this in
that's a question there is also possibly
night d 5 but after the tone I just play
C for you yeah I can just place it for
okay yeah I thought about that maybe
that's that's a good idea to immediately
disturb white if i cancel my castle
Queen c3 Bishop to a three kara it's not
clear that this radius is leading to
anything
okay well this is a bit lame but not
sure if there's anything better thank
you he much has it might might have
Queen d5 here nearly five Queen takes d5
yeah okay this is also possible
ok Jack 25 exactly yes that's a good
move yeah Queenie three years very meek
but okay come on it's not not nice but
it is so an equal position in any case
here black might even argue that he is
slightly better but I don't really
believe it trying to get get some some
weakness of the board here yeah there's
just very equal ish
got two minutes that's good to know a
big big-time problem
yeah okay
I'm wondering a bit about all that isn't
this dangerous I mean I'm behind the
pawn and send everything cannot go king
came to be 50 k like oh it will go he
will go to to the a foul thats that's
clear
just waiting here for a moment 50 50 k 5
i'll get to again I get to see 5 and
take both porn so it's it's becoming a
bit rocky now I don't threaten something
though I don't really threaten something
and maybe maybe look v1 it's not the
real threat the problem is a key I don't
threaten a 6 which would be quite
logical in a way but you can just take
it then maybe root people now this could
could be a threat now I can just take it
okay one can be six is the same thing
thats sssa 60 k is trying something else
that's it's interesting going 4 C 5 but
this is this is rather quick isn't it
okay
time warning
yeah k9 King picking c5 I have this
activity here would be 66 might I think
I get both pawns this is the now there's
a meter maid threatened rook a one I get
here slam there's some way to not give
up pawns
I didn't see I didn't see anything right
here really that's not not ideal not at
all
yeah it should be a draw i think i mean
that hard to believe I can win but
losing also looks unlikely nobody's
taking lots of time
Jay just stood wrong check yeah but not
with this time just letting the clock
run down yeah and the theater I still
think it oh it's a winner okay I thought
that those two could could be a draw I
wasn't I wasn't totally sure how is this
how is this a window let's check this
will this this is not winning which is
what i thought the kansai wants to play
this and now look be tuned yeah I'm just
promoting haha I'm just promoting like
that check
check yeah I'm and I'm quick enough
young I'm cook enough yeah okay tough
very tough and it seems that i'm winning
here anyway which I didn't think so
where other computer doesn't plus 3 plus
4 so it probably sees the win yeah I was
surprised I'm surprised that this is a
win but okay oops I'm sorry I'm a bit
surprised about that that this is a wind
butter came I'd like to briefly check
here this end game okay it seems that
this was a mistake interestingly enough
rook a7 was better with this idea and
this is some equal and ok and this yeah
this null leads to this tricky end game
which is really difficult to play for
black I wasn't sure about the evaluation
but it seems that it should win for
white interesting I didn't I didn't
think so because while you give up both
pawns and very often you should have
enough counter play with both ports but
there are of course as far away from
queening as possible so and this is a
William okay interesting thanks for
watching